the libs are absolutely losing it over
the Supreme Court's apparent decision to
overrule Roe versus Wade I'm not just
talking about the crazy hair color
people on Tick Tock I'm also talking
about the crazy United States senators
Senator liawatha had a full-scale
emotional breakdown over the Court's
apparent willingness to maybe sort of
kind of restrict her ability to kill
little babies
angry and upset and determined the
United States Congress can keep the law
of the land they just need to do it I've
never seen you so angry you seem to be
that's just what the Republicans have
been working toward this day for decades
they have been out there plotting
carefully cultivating these Supreme
Court Justices so they could have a
maturity on the bench who would
accomplish something that the majority
of Americans do not want 69 of people
across this country across this country
red States and blue States old people
and young people want Roe versus way to
maintains
we have a right
this shrill lunatic is on the verge of
angry tears because the Supreme Court
might take her Tomahawk away you can
look into her eyes and see a kind of
Madness this is no mere political issue
you look into a Raj you're seeing the
sense that quetzacodyl is going to be
deprived of his human sacrifices that's
the kind of issue we're talking about
here okay because Roe versus Wade and
Planned Parenthood be Casey and in this
case Dobbs versus Jackson Women's Health
Organization these are not ordinary
political cases okay and I would expect
more leaks and I would expect a whole
lot more than leeks because this is
about much more than some esoteric
debate about the nature of the law this
for the left is religious I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Ryan reinbo
who says Jesus says this is my body
which will be given up for you the left
says this is your body which will be
given up for me this is a very good
point actually the philosopher Peter
craft put it slightly differently but
the same sort of idea he said that
abortion is the antichrist's sacrament
that abortion uses the in the the very
same phrase actually that you see in the
mass this is my body uh in a in a
blasphemously inverted way because the
women say this is my body this is my
body my choice that's the mantra
of the pro-abortion movement it's so
perfectly inverted as to send a chill
down anybody's spine I think I think
actually regardless of your your
religious views or the the way you look
at other kind of political issues you
can just tell there's something that's a
little bit different about this issue
the libs are absolutely losing it over
this Dobbs decision which isn't even
official yet by the way we covered it
yesterday there was this leak from the
Supreme Court uh probably the the
predominant Theory right now is that it
was a law clerk for one of the more
leftist justices and most people seem to
think it would be a Justice in Sonia
sotomayor's office again this is just
speculation but the reasoning here is
that Sonia Sotomayor is by far the
furthest left and most partisan judge
and so it would seem likely that she
would hire very far left very partisan
law clerks there are something like
12 people that this could be
when you look at the number of Supreme
Court law clerks there are
period and then you look at the number
of Supreme Court law clerks there are
for the liberal justices who had seen
this was leaked by a liberal Justice
then we were talking about maybe a dozen
people that this could be so they'll
they'll they're investigating it right
now the Chief Justice Sean Roberts has
ordered an investigation but the leak
has already achieved its purpose which
is to get the left wild angry outside
demonstrating putting a lot of political
pressure on the court and trying to flip
the votes there hasn't been a firm vote
on this yet Roe versus Wade has not yet
officially been overruled we hope it
will be but we don't yet know and the
lift is already going into overdrive
about it Eric swalwell
Former Future president of the United
States one of the first guys out of the
2020 Democrat presidential primaries
Eric swalwell who then embarrassed
himself on National Television Eric
swalwell who was then found to be
bumping uglies with the Chinese spy Eric
swalwell tweeted out the Republicans
won't stop with Banning abortion they
want to ban interracial marriage do you
want to save that well then you should
probably vote
what so the first part Republicans want
to ban abortion true
Republicans want to ban interracial
marriage not true not only not true but
not related in any way to the it would
be it would be like saying the
Republicans won't stop with Banning
abortion
and they they like to put pineapple on
pizza too when you you do you support
pineapple on Pizza vote for me it's just
completely unrelated end the claim they
make is not true and also it's very
difficult for Democrats to make the
claim that the pro-life movement is
racist Democrats always revert to this
line of calling their opponents racist
because it's all they've got when a
leftist calls you a racist you know
you've won the argument and they do it
completely baselessly but they only do
it because to be called a racist is to
be called the worst possible thing you
can be in modern America so they just do
it without any basis but it's especially
Preposterous with the issue of abortion
because black babies are
disproportionately the victims of
abortion the pro-life movement
disproportionately is saving black
babies the abortion rate among black
women is five times the abortion rate
among white women
that's not even a number according to a
pro-life Research Center that's
according to the guttmacher Institute
that's according to the pro-abortion
center and they're admitting yes
abortion kills
five times as many black babies as it
kills white babies in New York more
black babies are aborted than born
in New York the most dangerous place for
a black person is in his mother's womb
so the pro-life movement
really doesn't have anything to do with
race
the pro-life movement is simply about
saving babies from being killed race
doesn't play a role in it but if you're
going to insist on making race an issue
here then
the pro-life movement is one of the most
pro-black movements in the entire
probably the single most pro-black
movement in the entire country but what
is Eric swalwell know nothing he's just
desperate so he's scraping the bottle of
the barrel here that's what Democrats
are trying to do and frankly swalwell
was more articulate than Joe Biden which
is damning with faint praise but but Joe
Biden was asked his thoughts about this
leaked decision and he almost formed a
coherent English sentence
the idea that we're going to make the
Judgment that is going to say that
no one can make the judgment to choose
to abort a child
based on a decision by the Supreme Court
I think goes way overboard
and the decision that we're going to be
and we're deciding and and no one
decides we're going to have no abortion
come on man come on Jack come on here
Corn Pop that's just too much man
give me an ice cream cone so it would
seem that the point he's trying to make
is that the court should not overrule
Roe versus Wade and then we know
elsewhere Biden has said Roe versus Wade
is so Central so important
to in the words of John Federman who's
the lieutenant governor of Pennsylvania
now Democrat candidate for Senate
abortion is sacred they actually say
abortion is sacred
just like every demon worshiping tribe
in the history of the world that's
sacred to sacrifice little babies
because Biden and the Democrats have
taken up this line
they're saying that if the court does
overrule row and does get rid of the
fictional National right to an abortion
that we need a national law
passed by Congress to codify that
abortion protection
that license to abortion into law the
the mistake that Joe makes here in his
line is he he admits that abortion kills
a baby
because what what the Democrats have
been doing in recent years I say
Democrats or I say leftists or I say the
pro-abortion movement there is some
distinction between the the three but
not much there used to be much more of a
distinction like back when Joe Biden was
Voting to try to overturn Roe versus
Wade in the States you forget that do we
all forget that I guess we do the New
York Times actually didn't forget this
about three years ago the headline when
Joe Biden voted to let States overturn
Roe versus way of the year was 1981
there was an amendment that was being
proposed by uh Senator hatch I guess it
was uh the the amendment would have over
overruled Roe versus Wade at the state
level and said states can get rid of Roe
if they want to because there's no
constitutional right to an abortion Joe
Biden voted for that Amendment so he
voted practically speaking to over rule
row now he's completely changed his
views on this but he hasn't changed his
rhetoric all that much and so even in
that in that clip of Biden defending
wrote Roe versus Wade and saying we
shouldn't overrule it he says we need
the right to abort a child
a child I thought it was a clump of cell
Joe I thought it was just just a zygote
or a blastula or whatever silly
scientific term they used to describe a
baby and Joe Joe didn't do that he said
no you need to be able to abort a child
in the words of Naomi Wolf the feminist
who I thought gave a very honest
description of the left's view of
abortion she said now probably 25 years
ago she said we need to admit that the
baby is a baby the baby is alive and
women need the right to kill that baby
in all of its Humanity if they want to
be the same as men
ghastly it's a horrific opinion
but at least she's being honest there
at least Joe Biden was accidentally
being honest there yeah we're aborting a
child
not even just a baby a child a mother
killing her own child what a society in
which mothers kill their own children
will do anything there's no limit to
what they can do
and this is a big change
big change for Joe Biden who once had I
think sincere opposition to abortion at
the very least it was politically
convenient for him now whatever
sincerity that was and whatever
convenience existed that's totally gone
the guy is full throatedly in support
of ritual human sacrifice
that's not good that's really bad for
our political situation it's not good to
have a president who is pushing that
sort of thing we're in a very tense
moment in American politics when you
want to be able to relax a little bit I
strongly recommend you check out the
bowling Branch right now go to
bowlingbranch.com use promo code Michael
to get my absolute favorite sheets I
love these sheets I have been using them
for what six seven years now I got my
first set for free when they came on the
show bowling branch has been a great
supporter of this show for a long time
but they got me hooked they're like a
drug dealer you know they give you the
first little taste free and then you're
totally hooked on it I started buying
them for my family I I bought new sheets
for myself when I upgraded the size of
my mattress they're just phenomenal
three United States presidents sleep on
bowling branch and love them three U.S
presidents and one beloved podcast host
they've got ten thousand Stellar reviews
uh bowling Branch signature sheets come
in nine versatile colors in all sizes up
to California King which is my size bed
they're 100 free from toxins no
pesticides no formaldehyde No nasty
stuff they give you a 30 night risk-free
trial you're absolutely gonna love the
sheets you could they could give you a
300 eye trial it wouldn't matter you're
gonna love them 15 off right now your
first set of sheets when you use promo
code Michael at bowlingbranch.com
bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d-branch.com promo code
Michael
the opinion that was released from
Justice Alito the leak that that showed
up in Politico yesterday is legit
there was some question yesterday when
we were talking about it on the show we
said we don't know if it's real or not
it seems to be real it sounds like him
it looks like an opinion but we don't
know if it's real John Roberts confirmed
that it is real
and the Chief Justice said
to the extent
this betrayal of the confidences of the
Court was intended to undermine the
Integrity of our operations it will not
succeed the work of the Court will not
be affected in any way
uh
Court employees have an exemplary an
important tradition of respecting the
confidentiality of the judicial process
and upholding the trust of the Court
this was a singular and egregious breach
of that trust that is an affront to the
court and the community of public
servants who work here I have directed
the Marshal of the court to investigate
the source of the league so this is
legit we don't know exactly what the
opinion is going to turn out to be right
now it's just a draft and it seems as
though there is a 5-4 majority to
overrule Roe v Wade and Planned
Parenthood be Casey but we don't know
judges change their votes all the time
until the the decision is actually
handed down it's anybody's game it also
is even more complicated because it
looks like the vote was six to three
to uphold the Mississippi pro-life law
that triggered this case in the first
place
but then the vote was only 5-4 to to
overrule Roe v Wade and Planned
Parenthood be Casey so it looks like
John Roberts the Chief Justice may have
flipped or not not even flip just sided
with the conservatives on the law but
sided with the Liberals on upholding Roe
versus white and Planned Parenthood be
Casey but we don't know is the political
pressure going to work maybe is this the
end of the shenanigans here to try to
undo this decision I I strongly doubt it
Roe versus Wade
and Planned Parenthood because he and
Dobbs versus Jackson Women's Health
Organization
Roe is not an ordinary case
some cases in the history of the Supreme
Court exist chiefly as instruments to
debate esoteric legal questions there
was a case I'm reminded of called United
States versus 95 barrels alleged apple
cider vinegar
this case comes from 1924 I believe and
the case is over whether or not a a
packing company mislabeled its apple
cider vinegar because it said the
vinegar was from selected apples and in
fact the vinegar was from dried apples
and the court debated this subtle
distinction what that meant for the law
and it's it's a very interesting case to
debate in law school
on the other hand you've got a case like
Roe versus Wade which consigned 62
million babies and counting to Ritual
Slaughter
those are very different cases okay in
in one we can play by the Marquess of
Queensbury rules we can follow all the
Civilized customs and the Norms of the
court and we can have debates over the
minutia of these legal details the other
sorts of cases have much more urgent
practical implications and there there
is no case more urgent and more
practical than Roe v Wade it is truly a
matter of life and death to the tune of
almost a million human beings per year
it doesn't get more tangible than that
furthermore this is a religious issue
it's a religious issue for me it's a
religious issue for the pro-lifers who
think that it is extremely evil for a
country to condone the slaughter of
babies but it's a religious issue for
the left too which is calling this
sacred which is saying this is a sacred
right
which is saying that
for women to be truly free they must
have the license to kill their babies
Elizabeth Warren's crazy eyes and shrill
voice well I'm angry I've never been
this angry right you've never been this
angry because you've been driven to a
kind of religious mania because you're
worshiping demons that's why because
your your political actions
and the rituals that you were trying to
uphold are whether you know it or not
actually demonic because your actual all
you're doing is the same thing that
those Aztecs were doing the same thing
that ancient Middle Eastern tribes were
doing with moloch and ball you're just
sacrificing babies and you think it's
really scientistic and really modern and
enlightened because you're sacrificing
babies on the altar of ideologic
ideologized Liberation and on the altar
of career and on the altar of money and
on the altar of of individual autonomy
but it's just the same thing it's just
exactly the same thing that the the
ancient pagans of your were doing with
named demons such as moloch and ball
you're just sacrificing your babies
to to what you perceive to be a higher
calling which is in fact a much lower
calling
Okay the reason I bring all this up is
not
just to get into a a theological
discourse over the implications of
abortion that we could be here all day
if we did that but it's because we need
to be honest about what this case
represents
I mentioned yesterday that everyone was
surprised they were so surprised that
this unprecedented singular action in
the history of the court to leak this
document it destroys the trust of the
Court how could someone do this how
could someone do this they kill babies
what do you mean how could they do this
they do things that are a whole lot
worse I'm reminded of Norm Macdonald was
talking to the late great nor McDonald
was talking to Patton Oswald his fellow
comedian
and Patton Oswald said you know this
Bill Cosby issue The Bill Cosby sex
crimes I think the worst part of it is
the hypocrisy and Norm Macdonald
responded to him and said I don't think
so I think the worst part is the raping
in my experience most rapists are
hypocrites very few are open and
bragging about their their raping and
they say oh yeah I'm raping but I'm not
going to hide it okay I know it's not
politically correct but uh you know I'm
right and they say well at least he's
not a hypocrite because that would be
the worst thing right that was Norm's
funny way of pointing out that people
who commit enormous sins will more
easily commit lesser sins
people who
kill little babies it's about the most
enormous sin I can think of people who
defend the mass ritual Slaughter of
little babies I think they're going to
be able to upend some norms and
traditions at the court
I think they're going to probably be
capable of violating the trust of the
clerks okay because that's a much lesser
sin than the issue at hand and and the
pro-life movement has done a great job I
am not criticizing the pro-life movement
okay but
I fear that some of us in the pro-life
movement have believed our own press
releases for the better part of 50 years
now
pro-lifers have focused on the technical
unconstitutionality of Roe and Casey
they focused on this one line in
particular which they say almost
reflexively they say you know if Roe
versus Wade is overturned that actually
won't make abortion illegal that will
just return the issue of abortion to the
states and whether you support abortion
or oppose abortion I think we can all
agree that it belongs in the states and
specifically with the people through
their legislatures that's where it
belongs so we can decide the issue
however we want for ourselves
that's the official line
the line has worked apparently
it gave us this Alito opinion it could
severely restrict abortion
it's not the whole story there are some
conservative legal Scholars I'm thinking
of John finis and Robbie George who have
gone further to argue no actually the
Supreme Court should decide the issue of
abortion no actually the court has every
right and responsibility to decide the
issue of abortion because the 14th
Amendment provides equal protection and
the little babies should be protected by
the 14th Amendment
so actually they make an argument that
contradicts the main conservative
argument for it
that we should return it to the states
and give it into the hands of the people
they say no actually there is a
constitutional protection against
abortion but okay that argument didn't
win the argument that appears to have
won at the Supreme Court
is over the technical matter not so much
of what Roe versus Wade represents but
who has the right to decide the question
of abortion okay
fine whatever works any even
semi-plausible argument that works any
moral way
to restrict abortion is fined by me
but that will not be sufficient for us
to understand why the left is losing
their minds over this If This Were
merely just a sort of technical
interesting scholarly debate over who
gets to decide certain things in the
Constitution you wouldn't see Liz Warren
having steam come out of her ears and
fire in her eyes okay you wouldn't have
unprecedented singular violations of the
trust of the Court the reason this is
happening is because Roe v Wade is not
about federalism and Roe v Wade is not
about the separation of powers Roe v
Wade is about killing babies okay and
the stakes are extraordinarily High here
and
and we need to be honest about what this
case represents if we want to understand
what is going to occur into the future
because this leak that that is not the
end of the shenanigans around this case
that is the beginning of the shenanigans
around this case prepare for
attempts at court packing prepare for
attempts at passing a national right to
abortion prepare for attempts to get rid
of the filibuster to get through the
national right to abortion because Biden
doesn't have the votes to do it prepare
for mostly peaceful riots in the streets
prepare for lots of shrieking prepare
for the left to be basically ready to
burn down the Constitution
they've all already said that they're
going to do all of these things by the
way they've even mocked the court you've
seen prominent left-wing accounts on
Twitter and on social media that have
said why are we listening to these
judges we can completely ignore them who
cares we can push them off a bridge no
one would care why are we letting them
tell us how we need to live Our Lives
why are we letting them interpret the
law for us burn it down that's the kind
of language that they are using because
this issue cuts to the very heart of the
left not just political but religious
views
okay you can hear it
you can hear you got to listen to what
people are saying when you want to hear
very well by the way you've got to check
out MD hearing aid right now go to
mdhearingaid.com and use promo code
Knowles did you know that nine out of
ten people still buy hearing aids from
clinics and pay five thousand dollars or
more even though much more affordable
options exist that is why you've got to
check out MD hearing aid MD hearing aid
is an FDA registered rechargeable
hearing aid that costs a fraction of
what typical hearing aids cost MD
hearing aids volt plus model costs over
80 percent less than Clinic hearing aids
they bring Clinic level care right to
you via telemedicine from doctors and
licensed hearing professionals MD
hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who saw how many of his patients
needed hearing aids but couldn't afford
them I had a relative years ago who
really needed and wanted a hearing aid
but but didn't want to pay the insane
price tag and I said just get it just
get it anyway don't but now you've got
an option The Volt plus by the way if
you leave it on in the shower it's it's
actually safe in up to three feet of
water water resistant so get Clinic
level care for 80 less with MD hearing
aid go to mdhearingaid.com use promo
code Knowles to get the new buy one get
149.99 each when you buy a pair of deal
plus they're adding a free extra
charging case a 100 value just for
listeners of the Michael Knowles show
head on over to mdhearingaid.com use
promo code nulls get their new buy one
get 149.99 each when you buy a pair deal
the daily wire has accomplished a lot
this year if I do say so myself
we've announced our new platform DW kids
we're taking on Disney Hollywood even
Razer companies and rebuilding the
culture that the left has been handily
destroying because it's about time we do
something so that you can too stop
giving money to organizations that don't
respect you or what you believe
help us build Alternatives where the
left is tearing down foundations and
start today head over to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code Knowles kwles for
20 off and join us in our fight to
preserve the real American way of life
today we will be right back with a lot
more
thank you
woke corporations are getting in on the
freak out over the potential of
overruling Roe v Wade Amazon announced
on Monday that it would pay up to four
thousand dollars in travel expenses for
employees who want to go out of state to
get an abortion
this was at a staff meeting on Monday it
includes a bunch of medically related
travel expenses they will reimburse that
travel for you and pay for you to go get
medical care and they will pay for you
to go kill your baby this is according
to Reuters if an employee cannot get an
abortion within 100 miles of home
abortion will cover up to four grand
of course Amazon is doing this
and and we on the right by the way need
to be
brutally honest about why Amazon is
doing this Amazon is doing this in part
because it's a generally leftist
Corporation sure
yeah that's true Amazon is doing this in
part maybe because the leadership of
Amazon supports abortion yeah that's
probably true
but it's not just a leftism it's not
just cultural Marxism okay
it's also capitalism that is impelling
Amazon to do this
it is better for Amazon if its employees
kill their babies
it is it more expensive for Amazon and
worse for Amazon's production and
distribution schedule if its employees
do have babies
having babies really gums up the works
when you've got female employees because
you've got to give them probably a
little bit of time off before the baby
comes certainly right around the
delivery then you got to give them
maternity leave you got to pay for them
not to work then they're not going to be
as focused on their jobs let's just be
honest about it okay they're going to be
they're going to have to take a day off
here and there if the kid gets sick if
they can't get child care I mean ideally
the corporations think that the parents
can just ship the kid off to daycare
from day three but but you know maybe
it's not going to work out some days and
so the employees are not going to be
quite as reliable as the kids get a
little bit older and they need a little
bit more from Mommy maybe around the
community driving them here or there
maybe maybe mommy is going to have to
only work a few days a week it's not
good for the companies
to
have to deal with this labor issue and
so it is entirely in Amazon's economic
interest
to subsidize abortion for its employees
the kids are only going to cause
problems for Amazon's bottom line
that's not Marxism that's capitalism
and it's why I'm I'm all for I love
private property I love flourishing and
free markets I love a good free economy
as a as opposed to a communist sort of
economy
but this is why I don't worship at the
altar of the free market the way that
some people on the right do this is why
though I love the market I find the the
market to be an instrument to human
flourishing
private property is an essential
instrument toward human flourishing but
it's but it is an instrument pointed
toward the good of the whole political
Community if capitalism and private
property and private Enterprise are
being disordered and perverted and
abused to justify and incentivize the
killing of children then we've got to
stop that we have a responsibility in
the political Community to go in and say
no Amazon you don't get to you don't get
to subsidize your employees killing
their kids no we're gonna we're gonna
get together in our political Community
we're going to pass a law against that
we're going to restrict your free
actions in the free market we're going
to put onerous regulations on private
business and capitalism so that you
don't
pay to kill kids
because we know it's in your economic
interest we know you have an incentive
to do that so we're going to change that
incentive
every Marketplace we talk about the free
Marketplace in the economy we talk about
the free Marketplace of ideas and and
usually the way we refer to it as this
kind of rollicking open anarchistic
space almost where there are no rules
but that's not how marketplaces are
there are rules to marketplaces that's
what defines a Marketplace marketplaces
are within a certain geographical area
there are certain rules of etiquette and
behavior that you have to observe there
are zoning restrictions that you have to
observe
the same is true politically
and morally
Amazon does not have any right any
fundamental sacred right
to pay for its employees abortions and
and what we should do
at what once the Republicans retake the
house in Congress
they should pass a law and ban it and
Outlaw and say no it's not just you
Amazon it's anything you're not allowed
to pay for your employees abortions
there's no right to an abortion and
there's no right even for Private
Industry to do that either it's simply
wrong it's egregiously wrong and and
we're going to stop it
there are we have to we have to be
honest about some of the potential
pitfalls of capitalism or of our own
economic policies if we don't want to
lose our economic Vision because if our
if our vision for politics and the
economy gets perverted and leads to
really bad outcomes then it's going to
be overthrown and we're going to lose
the whole damn thing and we're going to
end up living under a bunch of commies
okay another another issue that we've
got to be careful with here when we talk
about capitalism and individualism is
what it does to the family
story here
beneficial
have you heard of fictosexuals
I had not now I have ficto sexual man
who married a 16 year old hologram can't
communicate with her after software
support was eliminated
Star-Crossed digital lovers here this is
a man a 38 year old Japanese man who wed
a holographic image of a 16 year old
blue-haired anime character so it's a
it's not that the it's not that the
technology is 16 years old but that the
character depicted is 16 years old the
character's name is Hatsune Miku and he
fell in love with this character
um
he he apparently had a difficult social
life he was bullied at work he was
ostracized and so he is now pretending
to be married to this
digital character but it's it's really
their star-crossed lovers because the
the company stopped updating the
software so now he can no longer even
pretend to interact with the Hologram
obviously this guy's got a lot of
problems uh he should he should receive
some help and his co-workers who were
bullying him should be nicer to him and
he should be brought into real
community
this sort of thing should not be
encouraged or even really permitted
the extremes of individualism the
extremes of do whatever you want as long
as it doesn't hurt me
uh that that has no place in a
conservative political philosophy it has
no place in
Japan or our country for that matter we
we live in a society we have a
responsibility toward one another this
fictosexual story is not just some weird
tabloid Quirk it's where Society is
headed
because what what lies at the bottom of
this is that reality
doesn't really matter anymore that's the
basis of this reality doesn't really
matter physical reality spiritual
reality we can now move into digital
real virtual reality the metaverse what
we can we can go and deny the realities
of sex we can pretend to be the opposite
sex if we wanted if we're living in the
metaverse it doesn't matter because our
bodies don't really play a role in
virtual reality we can deny our
community we can just fall in love with
a computer
and end up in a solipsistic hell
we can fall in love with a computer and
just end up in our own delusions and our
own fantasies and this is encouraged by
technology and by an extremely
individualist society and economy and
politics and that's not good that's not
going to make anybody happy this guy is
the fictosexual is not happy I bet he's
very lonely and very sad and he thinks
that pretending to be married to a
computer is making him happier and is
providing a sort of Band-Aid over the
pain but it's not making anything better
it's actually only making the condition
worse we've got to speak honestly about
that well that's what a lot of this
abortion debate is over
even the the kind of basic conservative
legal argument hey look if we overrule
Roe v Wade you can still get abortions
in in New York you can still get
abortions in California
that's fine that's fine by me but it's
not fine it's not fine okay there are
certain things are just true and other
and certain things are false certain
things are good and certain things are
bad and certain things shouldn't be
tolerated anywhere and we actually do
have the right to make that claim we
have the right to tell our fellow
Americans to some degree how to live
that's not authoritarian that's not
fascistic it's not totalitarian it's
called living in a society
it's called being a citizen that's
that's what that is and Americans once
understood that and we have become
alienated from that not only because of
the radical left not only because of
Marxism but also because of the the
disorders and perversions of a kind of
capitalism too and if we want to
preserve our traditional system of free
enterprise and private property and the
American way of life we need to be
honest about that and we need to correct
that sort of thing
speaking of romance speaking of virtual
digital Romance
skeet Davidson
Mr Pete skeet Davidson that guy from
Saturday Night Live who is destroying
Kanye West's marriage to Kim Kardashian
Pete Davidson has has taken his
predations to a new level he has gotten
the initials of Kanye West's children
tattooed on his neck
this is extremely creepy and weird
Behavior
he was texting Kanye he said hey man I
want us all to get along I just want to
be friends with your kids and Kanye said
you're never going near my kids
absolutely under no circumstances weirdo
get out of here and
you can tell a major difference between
the left and the right
based on where they fall on the Kanye
story I think a lot of people are just
going to ignore the Kanye story because
the Kardashians are an absolute plague
on American culture that's but
the Kardashians are very popular Kanye
West is probably the most popular
Entertainer in the world even skeet
Davidson is fairly popular and so
these people have our attention
the conservatives tend to be team Kanye
and and the libs tend to be team skeet
and Kim Kardashian
this is not only because Kanye West put
on the Maga hat and like Donald Trump
I think it actually has nothing to do
with it the reason is because Kanye West
very publicly wants to save his marriage
and keep his family together and raise
his children
and Kim Kardashian does an interview in
Vogue magazine and says my 40s are just
going to be about me enough of other
people enough of living my life for
other people like you know my kids and
my family and my responsibilities toward
my community and my God no no I'm just
going to do it for me me me me and I'm
going to date this meth head looking
Saturday Night Live comedian who gets my
kids names tattooed on his necks like a
total creep
that's what I'm going to do me me me and
the same thing with skeet who's going in
and taking another man's wife which is
just wrong
and the what the libs argue is well Kim
Kardashian wasn't happy in her marriage
and look there's no evidence that Kanye
West was abusive in any way that he was
some kind of ogre but you know he's a
weird guy he's eccentric I think
everyone knew that going in
and so Kim should just be able to leave
whenever she wants because the left has
absolutely no respect for marriage and
has been trying to destroy it for a long
time because getting back to our earlier
discussion about hyper individualism
the left and some portions of the right
actually agree on a fundamental
political issue they think that the
basic unit of society is the individual
the left says it's just the individual
and we have to collect them all together
into the collective and the and the
misguided part of the right says the
fundamental unit of society is the
individual and we've got to keep them
individuals those are two sides of the
same coin
that's why both of those ideologies as
they Advance seem to go in the same
direction whereas the actual alternative
is that the basic unit of society is not
the individual to be collectivized or
otherwise the basic unit of society is
the family
and the family provides a real bulwark
against the predations of the radicals
who want to upend our entire culture the
family is sacred you want to talk about
something that's actually sacred
it's the it's the family
left says it's sacred to destroy the
family whether through legislation or
through baby sacrifice or anything else
the right says no to preserve the family
is sacred
so what do we do about this what do we
do about a culture in which
kids are are
why across the country are the victims
of things like divorce of mommy bringing
creepy boyfriends like skeet Davidson
around of of tumultuous sorts of
relationships and upbringing the answer
is
make it a little harder to get divorced
I'm not even saying make it illegal to
get divorced but make it a little harder
to get divorced
until about half a century ago
you had to provide a reason to get
divorced when you enter into a marriage
you're signing a contract and it's not
just any kind of contract it's not like
you're just putting together an
accounting firm you're getting together
and saying I am making a vow to create a
fundamental political unit here with
babies with responsibilities
so it's going to be hard to get out of
it now for the last half century
we've had something called no fault
divorce that's been a disaster for
everyone for kids for husbands for wives
for everyone after a wife gets a few
wrinkles around her eyes the husband can
just leave her now with without having
to really do anything at all
without having to prove cause he can go
and shoot up his secretary
or the in this case the wife when she
gets sick of her husband's
eccentricities can just leave and take
the kids and expose the kids to some
creep like Pete Davidson
Kanye has nothing that he can do about
it that's not good it's not good for
anybody and it gives us a society in
which the skeet Davidsons of the world
can go in and screw up all of our
families don't do it don't let that
weirdo do it man
Earl and earlier American cult an
earlier insaneer American culture would
not have let skeet Davidson around its
kids but now that requires a change in
our politics and that requires a change
in our law a reversion to the
traditional American way of life and we
might be getting a change in our law
because we've got one of the most
vocally pro-family candidates right now
who just want a big Primary in Ohio
the Ohio GOP Senate primary has been one
of the weather veins to see which way
the GOP is moving and which way the
country is moving
this was the race between JD Vance
he's the author of hillbilly elegy he's
been running a campaign as the kind of
boy from Appalachia who's not going to
show for Mega corporations who's much
more of a trumpy kind of candidate who
says we need pro-family policies forget
all these kind of crazy intellectual
abstractions we need to support families
we need to support workers we need to
support the traditional American way of
life we got to watch out about trade we
got a seriously diminish immigration we
got to protect America
that was JD Vance's campaign
he was running against Josh Mandel Josh
Mandel
was one of the he was actually moving
much more in that direction as well but
he was widely perceived as being a
little bit more of the older kind of
conservative movement type so still you
know hardcore and right wing but maybe a
little bit more in the
of the tea party-ish variety I don't
know if that's exactly fair I that that
was the perception though
and then you had Matt Dolan he was a he
was an older Republican who uh was also
running for this seat
and JD Vance won
and the breakdown is really interesting
here because Trump endorsed JD Vance
Ted Cruz endorsed Josh Mandel
I don't know who endorsed Matt Dolan but
the race then came down to
Vance and Mandel
and Vance pulled it out
now there were a lot of questions about
these candidates because JD Vance had
been much more liberal at earlier parts
of his life he had said lots of mean and
nasty things about Donald Trump and
Trump endorsed him anyway and so there
were questions all these questions as
there always are about candidates of is
he sincere does he really mean it is he
really conservative same kinds of
accusations against Josh Mandel though
they were more focused on JD bands it it
that doesn't really matter that's not
really what I'm not I'm not talking
about what Will these politicians
actually do I'm talking about
what do they stand for what do they
represent
what's going to matter this is a huge
win a huge win for JD Vance
it's a huge win for Donald Trump
and it is a huge win for the new right
whatever the new right means
pro-family
anti-mega Corporation
Pro
America first anti-globalization
anti-immigration
pro-life
Pro raising a family on a single income
that that kind of political agenda that
one that got a big boost
the other candidate who is really
pushing those kinds of things is Blake
Masters who's running for Senate in
Arizona we'll see how that how that goes
depending on how these primaries shake
out and then depending on whether these
guys can make it into the Senate you
could see a major shift in the GOP and
in American politics
and it's not just about the technical
issues of well according to the
Constitution actually we have no right
to impose certain tariffs I know it's
not that it's a it's about pretty basic
stuff stop killing babies defend the
American way of life keep these weirdos
away from our kids whether we're talking
about in school or whether talking about
skeet in the Kardashian household like
really basic tangible stuff
so get ready for the Nazi comparisons
msnbc's midi Hassan is making the claim
now that not just JD Vance and not just
Donald Trump but pretty much all of the
Republicans are Nazis
I mean it's easy in American discols to
talk simplistically about the fall left
and the far right as two equally
dangerous Fringe blocks Elon Musk has
done it plenty of times just in the past
week
but here's the difference America's far
left wants to give us free health care
and free child care America's Far Right
wants to give us white supremacy and no
democracy and this asymmetrical
polarization of U.S politics would be
laughable if it weren't so horrifying we
are living through an unspeakably
dangerous moment the pro-q Anon
pro-neo-nazi faction of the Republican
party is poised to expand dramatically
come the midterms we're just two years
away from Donald Trump very possibly
re-seizing executive power
if that happens we may look back on this
past week as a pivotal moment when a
petulant and not so bright billionaire
casually bought one of the world's most
influential messaging machines and just
handed it to the far right there it is
did you hear that he brought it back to
Elon this is all about Elon Elon who is
a liberal guy who voted for Obama twice
who is a tech billionaire but thinks
that maybe huh I suppose some
conservatives should be able to speak a
little bit more freely on one of the big
Tech platforms
that is enough to elicit the shrieks of
neo-nazism and racism in the end of
democracy
because
the
conservatives get to have their voice
heard
it is ironic of course
I mean on this question of abortion
which is causing the libs to lose their
minds right now the conservative
argument that seems to be winning the
day is we need more democracy on this
issue
the Constitution does not definitively
answer this question of abortion so
you've got to leave the political issue
to the people
pro-democracy the libs are saying no we
don't want that kind of democracy no no
we need we need some radical leftist
lawyers to decide this question on the
Supreme Court much as they seem to hate
the Supreme Court they sure do love it
when when the Supreme Court enshrines
their radical and minority Vision in to
the Constitution
just writes it in there with invisible
link between the emanations and the
penumbras they now say that the Supreme
Court has lots of white people on it and
men in particular and they can't vote to
overrule Roe v Wade well the the court
that enshrined Roe v Wade was entirely
men
so what are you talking about
the arguments are not coherent and so
what it what it boils down to is the
same old thing it's racism Eric swalwell
says if you if you oppose the killing of
babies you're you probably you're racist
this guy on MSNBC it's Neo-Nazi if you
think conservatives should be able to
speak at all whatsoever on social media
you're a Nazi
this is
not the way that republics are supposed
to conduct our political debates this is
not civilized this is not standards this
is not Norms that Americans
have traditionally been used to
but that's because this issue is
different that's because this is not
just a little scholarly debate around a
classroom we're talking about questions
of life and death expect it to become
much much more not less much much more
intense I'm Michael knows it's the
Michael Knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
production manager Pavel vidovsky editor
and Associate producer Danny D'Amico
associate producer Justine Turley audio
mixer Mike coromina and hair and makeup
by Cherokee heart Michael Knoll show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2022. on the Matt wall show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you your family our country
not just politics but culture Faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show